>> Tucker: THERE'S NOT MUCH
QUESTION THAT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION'S BUY THEM A
DONALD TRUMP FOR
PRESIDENT CAMPAIGN.
A GOVERNMENT INFORMANT ON THE
GOVERNMENT PAYROLL APPROACHED AT
LEAST THREE MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, SECRETLY GATHERED
INFORMATION FROM THEM AND IT
SECRETLY PASSED IT BACK TO
GOVERNMENT HANDLERS IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
YOU CAN CLAIM ALL OF THAT WAS
JUSTIFIED, YOU CAN'T CLAIM IT
WAS INSPIRING BECAUSE IT WAS
INSPIRING.
DEMOCRATS ARE CONTINUING TO
INSULT YOUR INTELLIGENCE THAT IT
WASN'T SOMEHOW.
HERE IS CONGRESSMAN ON THIS
PROGRAM JUST LAST NIGHT.
TELL ME WHY SPYING ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN WAS JUST SPYING, SPEAK
SLOWLY SO I CAN UNDERSTAND.
>> THEY WERE CONDUCTING A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT JUST
DEMOCRATS WHO WERE LYING ABOUT
THIS, OBEDIENT SERVANTS FROM THE
NATIONAL SECURITY STATE FROM
BOTH PARTIES ARE PARTICIPATING
IN THIS COVER-UP, THE MEDIA
MINDLESS AND LEMMINGLIKE AS
ALWAYS IS DUTIFULLY BACKING THEM
UP, HERE'S A PRESELECTION.
>> I'M MORE CONVINCED THE FBI
DID EXACTLY WHAT MY FELLOW
CITIZENS WANTED THEM TO DO WHEN
THEY GOT THE INFORMATION THEY
GOT IT AND IT HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH DONALD TRUMP.
>> THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THERE WAS
A SPY IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> ALL THE OTHER PEOPLE ARE
SAYING THERE'S JUST NO THERE
THERE, I'M WONDERING WHAT IT
WOULD TAKE FOR YOU TO SAY THEY
ARE FULL OF IT.
>> Tucker: LET'S TRY THIS
AGAIN, RICHARD PAINTERS A
PROFESSOR OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
MINNESOTA, HE IS NOW SEEKING THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION FOR SENATE
IN THE STATE OF MINNESOTA,
THANKS A LOT FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: WE KNOW AN FBI AND
CIA INFORMANT ON THE GOVERNMENT
PAYROLL MADE CONTACT WITH AT
LEAST THREE MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN DURING THE CAMPAIGN,
GATHERED INFORMATION FROM THEM
SURREPTITIOUSLY AND PASSED IT
BACK TO THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
YOU CAN ARGUE THAT'S JUSTIFIED
AND I'M OPEN MINDED.
THAT'S FINE, TELL ME WHY IT'S
NOT SPYING.
>> THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES IS ALREADY
TALKED ABOUT THIS, RICHARD BURR
IN THE UNITED STATES
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
THEY HAVE SEEN THE RELEVANT
INFORMATION INCLUDING A LOT OF
THEM HAVE SEEN THE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION WHICH I HAVE NOT
SEEN AND NEITHER HAS FOX NEWS
THE CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AND I
DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS A NEWS
CHANNEL OR A FICTION CHANNEL, WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON THE FACTOR.
>> Tucker: SLOW DOWN.
IF YOU WOULD, PLEASE STOP WITH
THE INVECTIVE AND EXPLAINED TO
ME, BEGIN SLOWLY WHY GIVEN THE
FACT SET THAT I JUST PRESENTED
TO YOU AND I THINK WE CAN AGREE
THAT'S TRUE THAT'S SPYING.
UNDER WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
NOT SPYING?
>> THE SPEAKER OF THE RED STATES
OF REPRESENTATIVES LOOK AT
THAT -- INCLUDE IN THE
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION WHICH I
HAVE NOT SEEN.
>> Tucker: YOU'VE ALREADY SAID
THAT.
I UNDERSTAND, YOU JUST CONFIRMED
THAT WHATEVER REPUBLICAN LEADERS
SAY YOU BELIEVE.
IT'S ODD YOUR RUNNING AS A
DEMOCRAT.
SUGGEST TO ME, SPECULATE GO
CRAZY AS A FORMER LAW PROFESSOR,
THE FACTS THAT I JUST LAID OUT
THAT ARE NOT CONTESTED DO NOT
AMOUNT TO SPYING -- NOT WHETHER
THERE JUSTIFIED, BUT WHETHER
IT'S SMILING.
>> ANY REPUBLICAN WHO SAW A
SHRED OF EVIDENCE THAT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WASN'T SPYING ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WOULD CLEARLY
HAVE SAID IT WAS SPYING.
>> Tucker: THAT'S YOUR
EXPLANATION?
I'M ASKING YOU AS SOMEONE
RUNNING FOR OFFICE, TELL ME WHY
GIVEN WHAT I JUST SAID I'M GOING
TO ASK YOU FOR THE THIRD TIME
IT'S REALLY SIMPLE.
I'M NOT ASKING WHETHER IT WAS
JUSTIFIED OR NOT, IT MAY HAVE
BEEN.
WHY IS THAT NOT SPYING?
SECRETLY GATHERING INFORMATION
ON SOMEBODY AND PASSING IT BACK
TO YOUR HANDLERS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION IS EXPIRING BUT
YOU WON'T CONCEDE IT IS BECAUSE
TREY GOWDY SAYS IT'S NOT?
I'M CONFUSED BY THIS
CONVERSATION.
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER WHETHER A
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN -- THE
FBI HAS A JOB TO DO, IF THE
RUSSIANS ARE TRYING TO
DESTABILIZE OUR COUNTRY AS
THEY'VE BEEN TRYING TO
DEDESTABILIZE WESTERN
DEMOCRACIES FOR A HUNDRED YEARS
OUR FBI HAS AN OBLIGATION TO
FIND OUT WHO WAS INTERFACING
WITH THE RUSSIANS AND THEY GOT
THE FISA WARRANTS FROM THE JUDGE
AND FOLLOW THEM FAITHFULLY.
>> Tucker: WAS THERE IF I
WARRANT IN THIS SPECIFIC CASE?
THE FIRST CONTACT BETWEEN THE
FBI AND CIA INFORMANT BECAUSE
THE FIRST CONTACT TOOK PLACE IN
JULY OF 2016, THAT WAS THREE
WEEKS BEFORE THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION STARTED, WAS THERE
A WANT FOR THAT?
>> THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE, THE
FBI ACTED INAPPROPRIATELY.
THEY'VE CONCLUDED THE FBI -- YOU
CAN CONTINUE TO MAKE UP
STORIES --
>> Tucker: SLOW DOWN.
STOP WITH THE INSULTS.
I'M NOT MAKING UP STORIES, I'M
STATING KNOWN FACTS WHICH YOU
ARE NOT CONTRADICTING, NOBODY IS
CONTRADICTING WE KNOW THIS TO BE
TRUE UNLESS WE ARE WRONG IN
WHICH CASE TELL ME HOW I'M WRONG
BUT YOU HAVEN'T AND I'M ASKING
YOU GIVEN THAT HAPPENED WHY ARE
WE SURE THAT WAS JUSTIFIED IF IT
TOOK PLACE BEFORE THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION OPENED?
YOU SUGGESTED IT WAS A FISA
WARRANT THAT MADE THAT LEGAL, DO
YOU HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF THAT OR
YOU MAKING THAT UP?
>> I AM SAYING MEMBERS OF THE
HOUSE AND SENATE TO HAVE LOOKED
AT THE CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
WHICH I HAVE NOT SEEN, DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS HAVE CONCLUDED
THAT THE FBI ACTED APPROPRIATELY
ENCOUNTERING A FOREIGN FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE OPERATION INSIDE
THE UNITED STATES AND IT
DESTABILIZING OUR COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: I WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW MORE AND YOU'RE ATTACKING
ME FOR WANT TO KNOW MORE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO KNOW WHO
AUTHORIZED THIS?
ON WHAT LEGAL BASIS DID THIS
TAKE PLACE?
ARE THESE INTERESTING QUESTION
TO YOU OR DO YOU THINK IT'S
UNPATRIOTIC TO ASK THEM?
>> I WANT TO KNOW WHY THE FBI
DIDN'T UNCOVER WHAT THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN WAS DOING IN 2016
INCLUDING THE TRUMP TOWER
MEETING AND BLOW THE COVER ON
THAT, SO WE WOULD HAVE KNOWN
ABOUT THAT BEFORE THE ELECTION.
WE SHOULD HAVE KNOWN ABOUT THAT
AND THE FBI DIDN'T DISCLOSE WHAT
THEY KNEW ABOUT THE RUSSIANS AND
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN COLLUDING.
WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN TOLD AND
THAT'S WRONG.
>> Tucker: I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
UNFORTUNATELY WERE OUT OF TIME.
GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR SENATE RACE
I HOPE VOTERS UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING BECAUSE I CAN'T.
ANDREW McCARTHY IS A FORMER
ASSISTANT U.S. ATTORNEY FOR THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK
AND HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THE SEMANTIC SMOKE SCREEN, I
THINK IT IS A SEMANTIC
SMOKE SCREEN IF YOU DISAGREE
TELL ME.
THE DEEPER QUESTION IS IS THERE
A PRIZE A WARRANT FOR THIS?
>> THERE IS A SEMANTIC
DIFFERENCE, EVEN CHAIRMAN TREY
GOWDY WHO OBJECTED TO THE WORD
SPY INSISTED IT WAS AN
INFORMANT.
ON ONE SIDE OF THIS YOU HAVE
PEOPLE WHO WERE ENGAGED IN
HYPERBOLE, THEY WERE ENGAGED IN
EUPHEMISM BUT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE SAME THING.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A COVERT
OPERATIVE WHO WAS SENT GAIN
INFORMATION.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE A FISA
SURVEILLANCE WARRANT TO USE ON
INFORMANT, IN FACT IT'S A PRETTY
LOW STANDARD.
WE KNOW THERE WAS SOME FISA
SURVEILLANCE THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
MORE THAN WE KNOW ABOUT BUT THAT
BEGAN IN OCTOBER AND IT WENT FOR
BASICALLY MOST OF THE NEXT YEAR
WELL INTO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THEY WERE USING ON INFORMANT OR
A SPY -- AT LEAST ONE, AT LEAST
BEGINNING IN JULY AND I THINK
THE ISSUE HERE IS WHY THEY WERE
DOING IT, NOT WHAT YOU CALL IT.
THE MOST OBJECTIONABLE THING I
HEARD FROM YOUR LAST GUEST WAS
HE KEPT SAYING THE PEOPLE WHO
LOOKED AT THE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION -- IN POINT OF FACT,
THEY HAVEN'T SEEN THE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
A BIG PART OF WHAT THIS WHOLE
DEBATE HAS BEEN ABOUT HAS BEEN
THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
ASKING FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS
FROM THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
THE FBI TO SEE THE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION AND THEY HAVE BEEN
STONEWALLED.
>> Tucker: THAT CONVERSATION
WAS DEMENTED I'M STILL CONFUSED
BY IT.
THE CORE QUESTIONS REMAIN TELL
ME IF I'VE GOT THE TIME I'M
WRONG, APPARENTLY THE
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN
MISS INFORMANT IN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN BEGAN BEFORE THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION INTO CAMPAIGN TIES
TO RUSSIA BEGAN.
>> THE INVESTIGATION IS FORMALLY
OPENED WE THINK AROUND JULY
JULY 31ST.
WE ARE ALLOWED TO DO PRELIMINARY
STEPS BEFORE THEY OPEN A FULL
THROTTLE INVESTIGATION AND
PRESUMABLY THEY USED THAT
AUTHORIZATION OR THAT AUTHORITY
THAT THEY HAVE TO USE INFORMANTS
THAT THEY HAVE TO USE INFORMANT
INFORMANTS.
WE ARE SPECULATING BUT WE
SHOULDN'T BE SPECULATING AT THIS
POINT, WE SHOULD KNOW THE
ANSWERS.
WE SHOULD BE NOW AT THIS POINT
ABLE TO SAY EXACTLY WHEN THIS
INVESTIGATION OPENED NOT ON
PAPER BUT WHEN IT REALLY OPENED.
WHEN THEY STARTED TO DO STUFF.
>> Tucker: WE ARE OUT OF TIME
BUT FACT-CHECK IT FOR ME.
YOU NEED A HIGH BAR TO DO THIS.